la bourse maintenant avec jean le berre
jean est ce que la motivation est la
même que la semaine dernière la bourse
eh bien oui en fait on continuait sur le
train train comme vendredi l'indicateur
de tendance ne variaient pratiquement
pas c'est un score nul mais il y a
quelques minutes les étudiants en
médecine viennent d'envahir la bourse
donc sur les images derrière moi vous
voyez peut-être un certain nombre de
blouses blanches et cela n'empêche pas
les cotations et pour les boursiers il
explique ce piétinement de par deux
éléments un bon et un mauvais le mauvais
c'est le prélèvement exceptionnel de 1 %
sur les revenus financiers
mais ce prélèvement n'est pas une
surprise il était attendu des boursiers
le bon élément en revanche c'est la
hausse du dollar qui gagne 1%
aujourd'hui sur notre tableau nous avons
des reculs importants et conquis est au
plus bas de l'année qui perd 5,2 pour
cent plus cher et ça à 179 francs qui
perd 5% et avions dassault qui perd 3,2
pour cent sur le marché des devises je
vous le disais le dollar est à 6 francs
12 75
nous avons une rose technique du dollar
j'ai un petit peu de monde derrière moi
excusez moi
et selon les cambistes qui a crime in
hell en bon voilà on en n 8 et redonner
mois l'antenne gens parce que je pense
que vous serez perturbé que ça ça
s'appelle un viol d'image eh bien on
vous retrouvera tout à l'heure vous nous
donnerez l'est où les cotations
dénationaliser et des autres merci nous
allons aller à l'aise pour qu'ils ont
traitant avec daniel kazan je pense que
c'est plus calme